okay so moonai episode 1 was pretty wild
and god amit we have some big fan
theories about what could be going on in
the show throughout this video we're
going to be discussing what we think is
happening with steven's mother omits
plan why jake may already be in the
series and a lot more full spoilers
ahead so if you haven't had a chance to
check it out then check out now if you
don't want a bad rap like a monster in a
mummy movie then make sure you hit the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe with that out of the way my
name is paul bringing the fan theories
to y'all now let's get into moon knight
okay so episode one of the show sees
steven grant living a pretty lowly life
we're even introduced to the character
through the song man without love by
engelbert humperdinck and the guy spends
his days either at work or leaving
voicemails to his mother the first
theory i want to dive into is how his
mummy is as dead as a mummy second mummy
joke of the video now in case you don't
know in the comics mark is actually the
main personality and therefore if his
mother was alive she'd be like where's
my son and why is he talking in that
crap cockney accent we'll get into that
accent more later on but i don't think
that mrs grant actually exists and this
is why stephen is leaving voicemails and
receiving postcards instead of talking
to her directly in episode 1 we do get a
shot that focuses our attention on the
postcards being sold at steven's
workplace and therefore mark could be
buying them writing them out and then
sending them to himself so that it keeps
up the illusion that everything is fine
this would explain why he's buying
goldfishes and i think that the nemo
looking one we meet at the start of the
episode died this is why when stephen
goes to the pet store the assistant says
he was in the day before asking for one
thin goldfishes because mark wanted to
make it look like nothing had changed a
huge shout out to todd bincy on our last
video for pointing out that the second
goldfish doesn't eat any of the food
stephen puts out because it was likely
already fed by mark now if you look at
the comics there's also a big indicator
that steven's mother is dead mark had
quite a rough childhood and his mother
wendy sadly passed away when he was very
little trauma at a young age is actually
one of the main factors that causes
d.i.d it might actually be his mother's
death that set up this personality split
the moonlight collection by jeff lemire
actually shows us the first time that
steven was created and mark very much
viewed him as an imaginary friend
looking beyond this we know that
fernanda andrada has been cast as wendy
specter and with his actress being quite
young and that she's old enough to have
a kid steven grant's age thus she'll
likely be popping up in flashbacks and
down the line we might actually see the
events that led to her death playing out
in the series this would explain how
mark's did was formed all the voicemails
and postcards and be quite a big twist
if you're someone who doesn't watch 20
theory videos a week and have everything
all figured out because you refuse to
let yourself enjoy anything
congratulations welcome to the heavy
spoilers show
now it's time for a joke who should
stephen go to see after he broke his jaw
a chiropractor hey cairo cairo practice
that's a good night anyway one of the
big criticisms about oscar isaac's
performances steven is of course his
goofy linen accent just to clarify i
find it quite funny and actually like
what he's doing with it but there are a
lot of people online that out and out
hate it however lend me your ears
because i actually have a theory that it
might be bad on purpose
steven
you weren't supposed to see any of this
what are you you sure you want to know
now we know from the secret agent tv
spot that mark is going to be in line
with his comic book counterpart and that
the character will be an american
mercenary him actually being american
would explain why his british accent
isn't that good and it would make sense
as to why steven sounds a bit off he's
likely only developed this persona
recently so he wouldn't have everything
down and would just be doing a bad one
because no americans can do british
accents can you know be honest now yeah
right yeah write your best british
accent in the comments
anyway this sort of ties into another
point that's getting a lot of criticism
as many of you know mark is jewish but
this has been completely skipped over in
the show and it has caused a bit of
controversy mark being jewish was
purposely placed in the comics because
the writers wanted to explore the
relationship between an egyptian god and
a jewish person due to its roots in
religion this seems to be absent from
the show though they could also reveal
it through mark when we start to learn
more about him right now we are only
seeing things through the eyes of
stephen so i hope that it pops up down
the line at some point if we look at the
imdb cast we also apparently have elias
spector popping up who in the comics was
a rabbi that would end up bringing this
all together now ahmed's plan is still a
mystery at the moment and we know that
arthur harrow desperately wants the
golden scarab tv spots are revealed that
he eventually gets this and then it
takes him to what i'm guessing is egypt
resurrecting her is a big part of his
plan so that he can create heaven on
earth or as i call it my life if i
hadn't been forced to go see morbius for
this channel now at one point in the
episode harrow weighs the souls of two
people the first of these is a young man
and the second is an old woman the
former lives whilst the letter dies and
if we look at harrow's ranks it seems to
be full of guys just like this something
seems off and instead i think that army
is just recruiting those that are the
strongest so that harrow has more of a
chance of resurrecting her an old woman
likely has little use in fighting a war
and thus she's killed off because she'd
probably just be a burden now in
mythology ahmed is also known as the
zelda vara and it makes sense that she'd
have to eat souls in order to power
herself up good souls would probably
replenish herself more than bad ones
would and i think that good people are
being killed so that omi can feed
whereas the bad ones are being allowed
to remain behind in order to become
soldiers speaking of bad souls we are
still yet to be introduced to jake
lockley the third personality that
inhabits mark's body however however
however perhaps the jake personality is
the person that we've been dealing with
whilst most of us have assumed its mark
in the episode steven discovers a phone
with several missed calls from a woman
named layla who could potentially be a
loving dress for the character she has
been hitting his phone up quite a lot
and seems genuinely concerned about him
secondly all the scenes we get with mark
make him out to be a bit of a wreck
who's barely holding it together as he's
trapped behind the mirror in the comics
mark is a cold-blooded killer that isn't
really a ladies man and though he has a
love interest in a woman named marlene
he's always trying to keep a low profile
that's what this mark seems to be doing
too and if we all write about him buying
postcards and goldfishes to hide the
truth it doesn't make sense that he'd
set up dates this would have the
potential to set steven off to learn the
truth and therefore i kind of think that
it's actually jake who organized the
date mark probably also knows enough
about stephen to know he's a vegan and
the more that i think about it the more
likely it is that it's probably jake
behind all the date stuff jake might
have even ate the fish or something and
then mark would have had to rush out to
get another one so that steven didn't
suspect a thing i'd love for there to be
a big twist that reveals jake has been
there the entire time and we just didn't
know about it because we were so fixated
on the two lastly huge shout outs to
tease pv who pointed out that if you
scan the qr code in the museum then it
actually takes you to the marvel website
for moonlight great easter egg that i
didn't even pick up in our first
breakdown and it's always nice to see
when people do your job better than you
do it my hopes is that teaspv is
actually one of my offshoot
personalities like kevin's spoilers and
in a way yeah now i think about it i
actually found that easter egg it was
all me shout outs myself see you chump
anyway that concludes the video and of
course love to hear your thoughts on the
theories and if you have any then make
sure you leave them in the comments
below we have five weeks ahead of us of
this mind bending munite series and i
will be back at some point down the road
to discuss these theories more in depth
as well as what we've learned about the
show these will probably all turn out to
be wrong so don't be too precious on
them now we are running competition
right now and giving away three copies
of spider-man noway home on the 15th of
april all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts and theories we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
you want something else to watch the
meishi checkout or breakdown of the
first episode which will be linked on
screen right now point out some cool
easter eggs gave you some backstory on
moonlight just had a laugh with it so go
check it out right after this if not
thanks for sticking through the video
i've been poor i'll see you in the next
one take care peace